[Music]  after multiple reports of a UFO sighting  in Milford Texas a Twitter post showing  several men at what appears to be the  crash site past on fire calling  themselves lazer team this is neat in  less than five days an alien warrior  will arrive to do battle with whoever is  wearing this suit to the death the fate  of the earth hangs in the balance  soup is meant to work as a unit who's  this douchebag I'm the champion of Earth  [Music]  you'll now begin your formal training to  utilize your yes hot meal chef's I have  a question why the hell does he sound  British now what he's a stupid person  and that's what stupid people think  smart people sound like that play my dad  may not be very strong or brave but he  is really good I love you too sweetie no  matter what comes your way I will block  it  [Music]  [Music]  where's your orderly yeah he went away  with Valenti how bad a girl wants you  just see how long she says hey Mindy  [Applause]  [Music]  oh my god